one of the biggest mistakes i think
ultra runners can make is you find
yourself at the starting line of 100
mile race and you just create this
monster in your head of what you're
going to do and then you try to wrap
your head around that and you burn so
much mental energy thinking about that
all day that when you get to the end and
it's time to really push you've got
nothing left to give mentally you've
kind of drained that mental battery so
to speak
zac betta welcome to the show hey thanks
for having me how are you finding
training now that you're in austin has
it got the right the requisite trails
and running routes that you need
yeah you know the biggest transition for
me so far has just been going from like
a very oppressively hot dry climate in
phoenix to uh slightly more or i
shouldn't say slightly but much muggier
climate here in austin equally
oppressive but wetter yeah
yeah i grew up in the midwest i spent a
couple decades in wisconsin actually so
i got sort of familiar with humid summer
so i have an idea of what's what's
coming and you know one of the reasons
why my wife and i moved to austin was
because i ended up coming down here i
think five times last year and she was
already kind of interested in in moving
to austin at some point so we we decided
uh it was time to make it happen so but
yeah adjusting i'm training for mostly
flat stuff right now so
terrain isn't as big of an issue it's
just you know
normalizing the the temperatures more or
less we don't have a lot of elevation or
mountains in austin or at least i
haven't been to see any yet i haven't
been shown any of them
no they i mean they call it hill country
i guess so you can get some rollers but
uh not a lot of like two mile ascent
type of situations like you're gonna
find in like the canyons out in
california and stuff like that so it's a
little different uh i kind of like it
though i like running controlled
surfaces a little bit better i like
doing the trail stuff as well but
usually i'll use that as a way to kind
of like break up kind of big build ups
for more flatter races and that just
kind of keeps keeps me excited about it
makes it not quite as monotonous and i
think just kind of gives you a little
bit of an edge when you're kind of going
back and forth a little bit but i'm sure
once the summers really pick up we'll
head up to colorado for some some
training sessions up in
uh in the mountains if there's a race
that's kind of
targeting that type of terrain as well
what are you working towards right now
i'm actually preparing for an event that
as silly as it sounds it's on an indoor
track at the olympic training facility
in milwaukee wisconsin called the pettit
center and it's uh it's a little over
400 meter indoor track they have a speed
skating rink in there so they keep it at
like 60 degrees constants which is is
kind of a nice control there from a
weather standpoint and i'm probably
gonna do a 100 miles or distance
traveled in 12 hours there but i'm sort
of keeping the door open to do 24 hours
just in just in case but that's uh in
june so
everything i'm kind of doing from a
training standpoint is kind of
moving towards that you must be in the
thick of it then if that's what like
between six and eight weeks away or
something this must be
ramping up towards a pretty intense set
of training
weeks
yeah and when i do stuff that's kind of
like 100 miles and further i'm usually
compartmentalizing the different
intensities a little more than what a
lot of folks would probably think of
with an endurance plan
uh and the periodization is still there
it's just a little more structured so
that i'm working on say like shorter
intervals earlier in the plan
longer intervals or what you call like a
tempo run kind of in the middle and then
spending the last like six to eight
weeks working on kind of race specific
pacing which for longer races just tends
to be slower versus most endurance races
where race day is going to be kind of a
more faster paced comparatively to what
you're normally doing in training so i
think when you kind of stretch out the
distance as far as 100 miles and beyond
you get into this
this kind of territory where
you're really not going to cross a bunch
of different intensities on race days if
you're doing things right you're going
to kind of dial in the right intensity
and
hold on for dear life so to speak and
that just kind of puts in a position i
think to be a little more uh
one-dimensional throughout the uh the
different phases of training do you
still hold the 100-mile record
i have the american record for 100 miles
in distance running 12 miles but i uh i
lost the world record
to a guy named alex sorkin who's just
been on a tear he actually now holds the
world records for
24 hours
uh
12 hours 100 miles and 100 kilometers so
he's just been been ripping it up but
it'll be fun to kind of take a swing at
some of the times he's been putting up
the last do you know what the times are
yeah so he
he recently just broke the 100 kilometer
world record which was six hours and
five minutes so he's like sub six minute
miling essentially for sixty two and a
half miles or a hundred kilometers for
that his 100 mile uh pr is 10 hours and
51 minutes and what was yours before
mine was 11 hours and 19 minutes
so he took a good chunk off of that um
then he went 110 miles in 12 hours
so uh that's just distance or they do
these weird things in ultra running
where you see how far you can get in a
specific time frame so some popular ones
are like 12 hours 24 hours and then when
you get real crazy you do like 48 72 and
sometimes even six days
so he's gone up to 24
which he did i want to say that was
maybe about eight months ago he ran 192
and a half miles in 24 hours
so he's been just kind of lighting the
the flat runnable ultra scene on fire
recently it's been kind of cool to see
see him take a big swing at that stuff
is that indoors as well
his were all outside so
there was a an event he did two of them
at called the centurion 100 where they
have an outdoor track that is
designed for kind of record chasing they
try to minimize the field size so you're
not kind of spending too much time in
lane two or three if it gets real
crowded on the track
and uh
he did the 24 hour on i think it was
like a short loop around a mile a little
maybe a little over a mile and
yeah i think the other
i think the other so he's he's actually
run a hundred miles now twice since i
broke the world record and you did once
he ran 11 14 and that's kind of was his
first race
then he did 192 and a half for 24 hours
went back and did another 100 mile and
that's when he went 10 51
and then just i think was it a week ago
he did the hundred kilometer world
record um but yeah it's been been insane
to watch so six
like a sub six minute mile
uh sorry a sub six minutes kilometer
full mile for the 100 kilometer actually
so it's like i think it's like it's in
the 550s for for mile pace for that
and i think if my math is
right in my head it's like he's getting
around like
for his
he's down into like sub four kilometer
four minute kilometer pace for for some
of this
which is disgusting it is it's insane
it's it's really cool to see the sport
kind of kind of grow cause like i got an
ultra marathon running in 2010 and that
was kind of at the precipice of like a
big surge of popularity with the sport
and it just kind of continued to get
more
more popular over the last decade or so
and a lot of the growth was on kind of
the trails and the mountain side of it
and it was kind of a draw away from the
kind of more structured running that you
see historically but there's a pretty
big history and kind of flat runnable
control
short loop stuff timed events and things
like that so
as the sports continue to go we're
seeing this side of it kind of grow as
well and he's certainly doing his fair
share of putting a spotlight on some of
this stuff and the way that it works
because the 100 mile
and the 12-hour time tend to be so
tightly
uh close together you have a crack at
the first one and then if you feel like
you've got a little bit more in the tank
you just keep on going and see what
you've got and then maybe even have a
look at the 24 as well
yeah the latter is a little more rare
but
most uh i mean there's only a few people
who've been in a position to go under 12
for 100 and then
continue on so
it but that seems to be
the move i've only
i ran i did one time i stopped at 100
miles in 2015 i ran a hundred miles in
about 11 hours and 40 minutes and was
just like
burning in fumes basically so i stopped
with uh i always wondered about that one
how much of that one was uh just
my mental exhaustion which is the likely
case there versus just kind of
physically running out of steam but i
think usually when you're in a position
to be running a a time that's under 12
hours or in in alex's situation under 11
hours the motivation to kind of keep
going since you've put yourself in that
position is there and and you tend to to
stick it out even if it's at a slower
pace
24 gets interesting because there's just
so much more dynamics there in terms of
what you need to do for that extra 12
hours so i think it maybe looks
appealing when you cross that 12 hour
mark but then as you kind of tick up to
16 17 18 hours it gets a little more
daunting to maybe wrap your head around
that so
um
usually people are picking one or the
other or if they do pick both usually
only one of them goes well
talk me through a
controlled environment for hitting 100
miles how many breaks are you taking
through there are you trying to not stop
and refuel as you move pretty much for
the entire 12 hours
yeah as much as you can tolerate really
the only thing that should pull you off
of a track in an event like that if
you're going for just your fastest
potential time is a bathroom break so
what i'll usually do is i'll have like a
usually a couple people out there that
are just kind of at a at a table with
all my stuff and as i'm coming around
the loop if i want something i'll just
say what i want and then couple minutes
later they'll hand it to me so all the
like hydrating and fueling and things
i'm going to be doing
is going to be kind of on the fly so to
speak
and then it's just you uh you hope for
the best digestively and for bathroom
breaks and things like that
um
my my most efficient was
i did 100 miles with i think between 60
to 90 seconds of total stoppage total
stoppage yeah
12 hours basically yep yeah and then uh
when i ran my fastest time 11 hours 19
minutes that was i think i stopped for a
total maybe three three and a half
minutes total on that one
wow and then is that where do you
because i've seen certain races where
people take they have to recover they
have to either do a little bit of um
sleep or some sort of soft tissue or
just get lift their legs up or whatever
where's the line if it's not 12 hours is
it 24 is it 48
yeah it's a good question i mean if you
look at just like
world record performances and things
like that or record-breaking
performances
there's not going to be a lot of that
there's uh
i want to say
the previous american record for 24
hours a guy named mike morton when he
got near like the final hours he was
starting to really tighten up in like
the hamstring area and he would stop
every like four loops and do like this
stretch that seemed to kind of keep him
keep him moving a bit but
you know when you get to like alex
sorkin's world record his average pace
is right around seven and a half minute
mileing so
any stoppage there just means he's got
to run faster to average that time so
i'm pretty sure he had a pretty yeah
24 7 yeah 730 for the 24.
i think once you start getting to like
48 hours is where you start kind of
considering is like say a 20 minute
power nap gonna actually produce a
faster
overall distance versus staying out
there and slogging it and it's just you
know as you stretch out to those
distances too you just the fields get
thinner and thinner and the data points
get get less and less uh populated so
you do have a little bit of a variance i
i remember specifically i was following
there's a popular timed event race uh
actually down near phoenix
that they do every year at the end of at
the end of the year actually called
across the years because you start in
december and end in january
and the six days kind of their their big
calling card for that one and there was
a close battle between two guys a few
years back
and one of them
slept i think a total of somewhere in
the upper 20 hour time frame during it
and the other guy was like less than
eight hours total over the course of six
days so you do get a pretty big barrier
they ended up finishing in a not too
dissimilar time yeah they were close to
one another that's a one mile like kind
of dirt loop that they do that one on
and i want to say they were within like
a loop or two of one another by the end
of it all who's that crazy guy that did
the
the race that's kind of orienteering and
now it's one mile on the hour every hour
until still everybody quits
oh yeah the so
they've got these events called backyard
ultras essentially where
yeah you you have like a loop or
something that you need to complete in
an hour's time and it's just a last man
standing is what they'll call it because
everyone keeps going out until there's
one left the most recent one i think is
harvey lewis is probably who you're
thinking of is the guy that made what's
that called
there's a special trail
that he did for ages and ages and it was
a real sort of uh
interesting type of race the route was
always different it took a little bit of
orienteering to kind of get yourself
around i think you're thinking of the
barclays marathon i'm thinking of the
buccaneers yeah that was another
interesting one where it's
i mean it's all like kind of a mystery
they say it's a 20 mile loop that you do
five times but in reality they don't
really know it could be like much more
than that
and yeah it's like it's it's total
bushwhacking orienteering
and usually
it's got i think there's been
15 or 16
hopefully i'm not butchering this but
like 15 or 16 total finishes over the
years
uh and it's almost got to be like as
ideal weather as you can get for that
area if it's like rain coming in it's
basically a foregone conclusion that no
one's finishing that year even though
everyone goes in thinking all right i'm
gonna find a way so you get some some
crazy results with that one uh
gear uh was it gary robinson one year
he like the way they confirm that you
did the loop is they've got this book
and you're supposed to pull a page out
of it so when you come back down you
have to show the page that you did it
and he he came down but he came down
he had all his pages but he came down
the wrong trail so like he got turned
around somewhere out there ended up at
the finish area
but had taken a different route so he
essentially disqualified himself on the
fifth loop at the very end of the race
yeah imagine like spending almost 60
hours out there in the rain and
through all that and finding out oh i
made one mistake and that basically
bottomed everything out i
are you tempted by doing a last man
standing type race i would for that i
like i like the concept of the idea of
that where
there's kind of this
you're you're obviously in a battle with
yourself but there's like
100 different ways you can probably
structure that time frame
where with that hour in which you're
trying to pace yourself around and then
you're also trying to kind of monitor
the field and
sense like how much does this person
have left and how deep into the you know
the depths of sleep deprivation and
fatigue might have to go before someone
else breaks so i think i'll probably
do some of those eventually the the
interesting thing
i think is uh
you sort of get these hyper long ultra
marathons where age is definitely still
a factor but it's just pushed way back
so you can be a fair bit older and then
you have like
some of the racing that i've done more
historically i could call like single
day ultramarathon stuff where i do think
there's probably
a earlier
point where like all right now i'm
likely not physically going to be able
to produce the same times i was before
but you still have this door open for
some of those like multi-day type stuff
so part of me is kind of holding off a
little bit on that so that i don't spend
spend my youth so to speak in things
that i can wait for and maximize the the
shorter shorter distance ultras while i
still kind of have a little bit of pop
in my legs how old are you
36 okay cool and
is this
are you kind of looking at the the
precipice over the next whatever five to
ten years of the single day ultras maybe
being a little bit difficult to keep up
with does that start to look a little
bit more like a sprint when you're 45 or
46 instead of 36. 36
for sure and i think
it's actually in my mind that this is
something that i probably had to
re-re-learn or
re-evaluate in my mind as i thought
that as the sport kind of evolved
we did see kind of like a push of
younger folks coming into it where
historically it was kind of
you went through a full like sort of
like career if you want to call it that
or at least like personal like project
of seeing how fast you could run like
the 5k the 10k the half marathon the
marathon and then you'd sort of age out
and then
maybe if you still had some
some some fire in you you would decide
to do an ultra marathon so you'd see a
lot of the winners would be kind of a
little bit older than your average
athlete would be
uh we started seeing that get a little
younger as a sport grew but then
recently
we've seen the men's and women's hundred
miles 24 hours
uh 12 hours all go down to 40 year olds
so
now i'm thinking to myself well maybe i
got more time time left on the single
day stuff than i originally thought so
uh it is an interesting kind of a
thought experiment to run through your
mind but i think uh the 24 hour is going
to be something i'll spend a fair bit of
time training for and preparing for in
the future
and then
i don't know how much of the fort the
word on the street from the very
experienced multi-day folks is that the
48 hours the most brutal one because
that's the one where you could in theory
probably not sleep at all
whereas once you get up to like 72 plus
hours you're probably gonna have at
least some breaks in there
and uh it's just a lot to wrap your head
around i think from the mental side to
be going into a 40 hour race and
thinking like i'm gonna push through two
sleepless nights and try to stay
consistent and and on target for what
i'm going for and and that that one
sounds a little daunting so
perhaps i'll skip that and just do some
uh last man standing stuff
do you
have you got any concerns long term
about your health obviously i've heard
rumors or whatever seen things online
about free radicals from these people
that do tons and tons of endurance
events you know like absolute long-out
longevity is is that something that you
consider
yeah it's definitely something i think
about um
and it's
if when i'm like looking at what i do
relative to just running in general i've
clearly gone past like the mar like the
the health benefits and into like the
kind of masochistic territory of like
you're brutalizing your body and you're
gonna fight a little bit of an uphill
battle to probably keep things in check
so
um i think about that stuff i've just
been
i also i sort of look at life more
though through the lens of i want to
maximize
my time and enjoy
enjoy it as much as i can so if that
means like i'm taking some years off the
back end
in order to be like really able to go
after the things that interest me i'd
rather have that than be kind of more
moderate and find myself you know living
to be like 90 or 100 and kind of
wondering what if i would have pushed a
little harder or trained a little
differently so i'm definitely trying to
do things in a way where i feel it'll
keep me sustainable and keep me healthy
and not not destroy myself and some of
that i think is just being kind of
mindful of when injuries do pop up
making sure you're taking
the time to not let them fester into
something that's going to be long-term
or permanent
uh i think paying attention to nutrition
and things like that so that you don't
end up in a situation where you you're
constantly depleting yourself and
running yourself into the ground and
premature aging and things like that um
but at the end of the day it is probably
the you know like i said i probably
crossed that point where i'm maximizing
health through the activities i'm doing
and
leaning a little bit more into
performance at the expense of some
health but uh part of it is also i don't
necessarily see myself as being like
this 65 year old still out there kind of
slogging through ultramarathons for the
sake of doing it
my
my suspicion is that when i get to a
point where i'm no longer competitive
i'll probably focus my energies on some
sort of other physical type of thing and
maybe lean a little more into some
strength type stuff
and uh you know hopefully preserve some
lean muscle mass as i age yeah yeah man
it's it is interesting thinking about um
the people at the peak of their sport
you know you have the 100 mile record
for a chunk of time and then you're
going to go for it again this year
talking about life balance and
offsetting longevity and considerations
about that
all of those things are just mitigating
performance basically all of those
things are just going to get in the way
even if it's ever so slightly like you
know whatever it is that you decide that
you're not going to do with regards to
your training or your nutrition or your
whatever
it it's not going to be to the benefit
of your performance so if you are going
all out to try and be the best in the
world which you are i
it's interesting right because the role
model that we have
that we see in people that give
absolutely everything that they have
most people who aren't at the peak of
that sport because there's only you know
a handful that are
take that strategy as the one that they
should use in their daily life and i
think that you need to look at okay what
are the things that they are doing that
i can bring into my own life whilst
taking into account the fact that this
isn't my calling right i'm not trying to
get a world record i'm not going for
this this isn't my source of income my
desire for legacy
my highest calling in life
and trying to blend those two things
what is it that zach's doing that i can
bring on board myself that i think is a
good strategy but also
do i do i want to be ending myself to
the same degree that someone who's
trying to create this long-lasting
legacy is well
if you're just a
a recreational runner then maybe not
yeah it's a really good point because i
think it's it's funny i think actually
like because i coach people from like
beginners who barely ran at all in their
their entire life to people who've been
running their entire life and are you
know chasing like an age group record or
something like that
and
the difference i would i say between
like someone like myself who's doing
this as a career or a profession and
someone who's doing it as like a passion
but they also have a full-time job a
family you know a whole other life
outside of it
is they just have a lot more variables
that they're actually dealing with like
when you put yourself in a position
where you decide i'm gonna spend say
four to six months just living this life
of a professional athlete and do
everything i can to kind of maximize my
performance on one singular day you sort
of eliminate so many variables out of
necessity like you said you start
whittling things down where you just
draw your parameters so tight that you
have like a very
short list of things that could
negatively impact or impact what you're
trying to do
versus the everyday person who simply
can't turn those things off nor do they
necessarily want to
and where i find that interesting is a
lot of times we'll take things like like
studies and research on kind of training
methodology or nutrition and things like
that and we'll be looking at like the
elites the tip of the spear and it's
like
to a degree like you said there's a lot
of useful things you can pull out of
that but once you start introducing life
variables that are not present or
haven't been fine-tuned
to the degree that they are with a
professional athlete it starts getting
interesting and i think it gets more
exciting in terms of finding out like
well why does this work so well for me
but not for that person and then
you kind of have to play around with
some of those variables and figure out
why it's working for someone and not you
or vice versa
i'm interested by the mindset that you
need to be able to do that sort of an
event so obviously you're doing your
training you're doing your recovery
you're probably learning about different
strategies for
uh
fueling and refueling and intraday
workout
fuel and stuff like that
how much are you doing formal mindset
training is the are you working with a
mindset coach are you going through any
particular types of techniques that are
assisting you there
yeah you know the mindset side of the
sport has been something where i think
when i first got into it
i sort of just thought like it would
take care of itself more or less where
it was just you know my i think my
mindset about mindset was the reason i'm
doing this is because i have a strong
enough mindset to push through this
stuff and that was just like a
skill set that i didn't necessarily need
to practice or that was just kind of
unique
to someone who's doing this sort of a
this sort of a sport or this sort of an
activity but as i kind of went through
it i started recognizing just kind of
how you can train your mind differently
and and kind of structure the training
too so
for me now when i'm looking at
like my training schedule
i'm thinking about just like how do i
work on things like visualization
during training to try to kind of help
me close the gap between say the last
time i ran 100 miles and the next time
i'm going to
because the mindset of an ultra marathon
the uniqueness comes in the relative
limited amount of experiences you
actually have at it from a just like
being very specific to it so like you
never sorry you rarely run
100 miles in fact do you have you ever
run 100 miles in training
no
so what's the longest that you've ran as
not a competition
not a competition
60 miles yeah so barely half of yeah the
thing that you hold a record in right
yeah so when you think about it like
even like the marathon which we're
looking at standard endurance events is
kind of the pinnacle from a distance
standpoint not uncommon at all that even
like uh
folks that aren't elite will get up to
if not at that distance so at least they
can wrap their head around the amount of
time they're going to be out there
and you see the elites training for
marathons they're sometimes pushing up
upwards to like a long run where they're
doing 16 to 18 miles at gold marathon
pace so they've
narrowed that gap between executing
their race and what they've done in
training to a fairly small margin where
as long as something uncertain doesn't
happen
uh they can almost predict what they're
going to do on race day
whereas yeah 100 miling like the last
time you experienced mile 70 to 100 was
the last time you did it so
for me like the mindset side of things
is just practicing like visualizing
where you want to be
on event day and working yourself
through that and the best spot for that
i think is always when you're doing
things that are specific to what you're
doing so i really start to lean into the
mindset side of things a lot more when
i'm in about the last third of my
training build up where i'm really
starting to build up my long run and add
back to back long runs so i might find
myself on say like a saturday sunday
long run double where i'm running 30
miles on both of those days
and uh on that second one specifically
i'm gonna have a little bit of fatigue
from the training week uh there and i'm
just visualizing what is it gonna feel
like to move from mile 70 to 100 and
just like taking snapshots in my head
through that through these long runs so
that when i do get there on race day i
feel like it's kind of a little more
close proximity in terms of like what i
want to do how i want to do it
and i find that that's really helped me
kind of wrap my head around the whole
thing
because
one of the biggest mistakes i think
ultrarunners can make is you find
yourself at the starting line of 100
mile race
and you just create this monster in your
head of what you're going to do and then
you try to wrap your head around that
and you burn so much mental energy
thinking about that all day that when
you get to the end and it's time to
really push you've got nothing left to
give mentally you've kind of drained
that mental battery so to speak
and
if you can build that up and put
yourself in a position where you can
kind of work through those paces in your
head on a little more of an autopilot
because you felt like you've done it a
bunch of times i think that's the sweet
spot there so
that and uh
there's some other mental tricks i like
to use one is like intra race stuff
where you actually are breaking down
different segments so
like when i start a 100 mile race i'm
not going to be thinking about finishing
i'm going to be thinking about hitting
that first benchmark of where i'm going
to try to get to and what time i'm going
to try to hit there and and try to crowd
out any other thoughts if possible
i'm also going to be thinking about if i
find myself standing on the start line
of 100 mile race
i'm essentially like 99 of the way there
when i look at it from the entirety of
the training build up so
being mindful during the training so you
have these reference points to think
about
oh yeah four months ago i was there and
now i'm here and you know
three months ago i was you just have
these like mental pictures in your head
that really highlight the breadth of
everything and help you minimize the big
task at hand which i think is very
helpful in kind of getting yourself
positioned to be able to stay on top of
the the physical side of things uh with
your mindset zooming out is
so important it's such a difficult skill
though right we're so short-termist as
humans especially if discomforts in the
situation you're doing this thing and
all that you feel is the
taste of metal in the back of your
throat and the blood in your lungs and
the
throbbing of your legs and stuff
and you can't it's so hard you totally
right if you've been preparing for you
know
three to six months to go and do any
sort of a race and you're part way
through the race but you aren't it's 99
points something of the way there of all
of the time that you've spent
researching and looking at kit and
hydrating and diet and going on practice
runs and thinking about how the race is
all of that and you've just it's just
the end you know what's the it's the
final stage of the tour de france that's
basically like a trophy lap right it's
kind of just uh i can't remember what
they call it the the peloton just comes
in and it's um
symbolic right it's not it's not
actually part of the race so much and um
it's precisely the same as that
but except for the fact that you if you
get yourself in the wrong headspace you
probably can talk yourself into this
being this huge big problem that you
need to overcome and then you're going
to be stressed and you know that that's
not going to be good for your
performance and because you know it's
not good for your performance you're
thinking about the fact that the thing
you're thinking isn't going to be good
for your performance and it makes it
worse it makes it worse it spirals yeah
yeah
yeah it it's funny too because i think
in this maybe goes back to a little bit
to one of the questions you asked before
it's like
for me i think
when i don't belong on a starting line
of an ultra marathon any longer is when
i get to a point where
the process of preparing for is no
longer enjoyable they're no longer
fulfilling because
when you look at the race as kind of
like more of a celebration of all the
work you did to get there
then it becomes just kind of part of it
versus the the end-all be-all
and when people ask me like why i run
ultramarathons or if if they ask like
what they should do for running an
endurance race
i think digging into that is gotta be
square one it's like well what do you
actually wanna be doing on the
day-to-day how what kind of fulfillment
are you going to draw from this because
if
putting in the training is like pulling
teeth
then
it's not going to be something that
you're going to find enjoyment from even
with a good race result long term so at
that point it's probably more about
finding another activity that gets your
body moving that you do enjoy doing on a
day-to-day basis where the training
becomes such an enjoyable part of your
lifestyle
that even if you have a bad race you
don't look back at it and think well i
just wasted that last half year or third
of the year it's hard to compete with
somebody who's having fun really really
difficult to compete with someone who's
having fun right it's a competitive
advantage to do the thing that to you
feels like play and to everybody else
looks like work that's one of the things
everybody likes the idea of the
end result
uh
separate from the uh process that gets
you there everyone likes the idea of
being a rock star up on stage nobody
likes the idea of five to ten years
during your teenage years playing uh
sequences on the guitar over and over
and over again or like obsessing over
the way that your voice sounds or
getting going for vocal coaching three
times a week for a decade or something
right the same thing goes for podcasting
you know lots and lots of people like
the idea of doing a podcast we go okay
you're going to have to research the
absolute best people in a field within
the space of a couple of days they're
going to have had their entire life to
learn about this you've got a couple of
days to do it and then as soon as you've
done that you have somebody else waiting
in the wings like an endless conveyor
belt that's just constantly coming
around like is that do you like learning
about stuff at a
predefined cadence like running on a
treadmill because if you don't that that
is what being a podcaster is right like
what being a podcaster is is
consistently learning about lots and
lots of different things and then
managing to try and coax that out of the
expert that you're speaking to and if
you don't like the sound of that then
podcasting isn't for you i know that you
like the idea of that the same as you
like the idea of being a rock star you
like the idea of being an endurance
runner but if you don't want to go and
do lots of training and get to sleep and
miss out on social events and stop
drinking and do all of that stuff the
same as learning how to play the guitar
the same as reading the books or doing
the research and practicing on your
addiction and your conversation craft
the
end result is moot because the journey
to get there isn't something you're
prepared to go through
yeah i remember before before i kind of
changed career paths and focused more on
coaching and racing and stuff
i was a school teacher and uh i'd have
you know students who would you know
they
generally wanted to be doing something
other than being in school
and some of it's not their fault but uh
they would the stuff they'd want to do a
lot of times were you know what most you
know kids and teenagers want to do like
i want to go skateboarding i want to you
know play guitar like you mentioned and
things like that
and uh
eventually it would get to a point where
you're just like well well like what's
your long-term plan with this particular
thing and like well i want to be a
professional at it and if you want to be
professional at it it's like you have to
look at those examples like you
described and i would always share with
them um
zach wilds the
the lead vocal and guitars for uh black
label society who
when he was in high school
would play guitar i think something like
eight to ten hours a day
and would just be like super groggy
during school because he was up all
night basically playing guitar
but by the time he graduated high school
he was so good he had you know guys like
ozzy osbourne looking at him and it's
like that's what you kind of got to do
if you really want to be that guy
standing on stage and you know playing
lead guitar for ozzy osbourne or
something like that and obviously
there's other off-ramps to success
within those things that don't include
being the best of the best but these are
things you probably want to think about
as you're deciding you know is this
something that i really want to spend my
time and energy on versus
the endless list of other things that
are out there yeah and i think it's a
good idea to have a couple of pursuits
that you decide to try and be very very
good at i think that makes a lot of
sense but you can't do that for
everything and trying to do that for
everything is going to mean that the few
things that you should be really focused
on that you could perhaps become the
best in your
county city country world at
they're going to be diluted down by the
fact that you're trying to spin a ton of
different plates but i don't think that
it's a bad idea to recreationally have
something that you want to do or to
challenge yourself even once you know to
say look i really really feel like it
would be very meaningful to me if i
could run 100 miles i i don't think that
i can do it and yet it's going to be
this transformational experience it's
going to be interesting and i'm going to
learn a lot about it and i'm going to do
that like that's a very different
mindset
than i'm going to try and live the life
of a professional runner because i want
to try and become the best in the world
and you know that can maybe even
facilitate or improve the thing that you
have decided to be really really good at
whether that's running a business or
being a parent or you know being a
creator or whatever it is you want to do
um i do think that you can facilitate
that with stuff from outside of it but
this is the the core concept of greg
mcewen's essentialism where he says look
there's maybe between one and three
highest points of contribution that you
have to the world
everything else gets in the way like the
ultimate productivity system as far as i
can see is getting ruthlessly clear
about what you want and then culling
everything else that doesn't contribute
to it now running a hundred miles might
actually contribute to you being a
really good businessman because it may
teach you to overcome difficulty and to
lean into discomfort and all that sort
of stuff right but again like if
starting up knitting or something isn't
facilitating the thing that you're
supposed to do it's taking away from it
maybe that's something that you need to
question and the same thing goes for
whatever other pursuit you try and
introduce into your life
yeah you you hit on the head and i think
it's the one really interesting thing i
think about ultra marathoning in the 100
mile distance gets a lot of like
spotlight for this and part of it's
probably just because it's it does end
up kind of putting a lot of people in
this position where
they have like it's long enough where
there's just no way around some big ebbs
and flows and kind of your your mind
your your state of mind and your state
of how your body feels
that
kind of almost is counter intuitive to
you going in and the best example is
like there's like always going to be a
point in 100 mile race regardless of
whether you're finishing very last in
that group or in the very front or
somewhere in between where you get to a
point where you feel like you've hit
rock bottom
and your mind immediately goes to this
spot of like
if it's this bad now how can
i keep doing this and expect it not to
get worse
and if you let that continue to happen
like your mind to keep going down that
path you're gonna drop out
but if you kind of like hunker down
focus on a short-term goal and get
through that
it's amazing like you might have like
this scenario where five miles later you
feel better than you did all day long
and you're left there almost laughing at
yourself thinking like how did i
continue the activity that got me to
feel that miserable
and the continuation of that activity
actually now makes me feeling better
than i've ever felt before in my life
and you have all these experiences
balled up into essentially one day and
it's just like you you can almost live
like a lifetime worth of emotions in one
day
and the perspective you get from that is
like you said it bleeds into everything
because then let's say you are really
focused on a business that you started
and the 100 mile thing is just
like a side hobby that you're doing for
fulfillment or for whatever reason
and now you're at a point in your
business where you hit a very difficult
obstacle and it's like
like what do you do and you think back
to that experience you had running that
100-mile race and pushing through that
and you kind of leveraged the same
mindset you leverage the same
like visualization tactics the same
attitude and everything and then you end
up breaking through that and you have a
similar experience of oh now i hit a new
height with my business we've took this
to another stage or you know
another benchmark is met and things like
that and then you laugh at yourself for
thinking that you weren't able to do it
like earlier on and it's just a really
kind of rewarding experience i think can
you try and explain the uh typical
emotions over 100 miles from start until
finish for those of us that don't intend
on running it
sure yeah um
i the way i usually kind of think about
it is like you're gonna have essentially
for me it's like the first about 30
miles feels pretty good because
i have to be running slow enough that
it's sustainable for 100 miles i've
typically been doing like my long runs
up to about that distance so it's
something my body's still familiar with
the intensity is low enough where you
know i'm not feeling a ton of wear and
tear yet
and getting to that feels almost like a
snap of the fingers like you get to i
get to 30 miles and i like look back
like wow it feels like i just started
and then you start to kind of get into
this phase where if you give it
opportunity to think about you think
okay well i got 30 miles in my legs
that's the longest long run i did during
the build up
i got 70 miles to go and that kind of
plants a bit of a seed of doubt so now
you're thinking
can i do this two more times and then
some what happens if you know i start
feeling more miserable by 40 am i gonna
be able to do 60 more miles and you
start kind of getting that like negative
spiral so that's where i typically have
to start kind of focusing on like
positive self-talk and thinking about
uh how do i get myself to think about
the next goal and block out the end goal
at least until it becomes time to focus
on that so usually i'm kind of like
really kind of starting that mindset
from between miles 30 to 40 where i'm
focusing on consciously
minimizing my targets
and getting to them versus thinking too
far ahead and then when i get to the
next one picking the next one and then
there's some kind of like basic
benchmarks that i like to use one is
like 50 miles it's halfway there
uh it's also a race distance that i've
done a few times in the past so i have
some precedent in terms of like what i'm
capable of doing in that time or that
distance versus where i'm doing for the
pacing to kind of normalize okay i'm i'm
where i need to be i'm not being too
aggressive i'm not being too slow this
is this checks out so then that's kind
of a good goal to get to next one is
kind of like a hundred kilometers i like
to kind of start focusing on that one
after i've crossed the halfway mark
because again it's another race instance
i've done a few times
and have some perspective of how i
should feel relative to like going on
all-out effort there
and start kind of using those as kind of
like positive things to get to
once i get to around 100 kilometers
then i'm within like you know five to
ten miles of the longest long run i got
to so then my next goal is get to within
the longest long run you did
for that build up and then you just have
one more long run too so when i can get
to that spot if i've taken care of
myself properly that day and i'm in a
good like head space then i can almost
forget about doing 100 miles and start
thinking about i just got one more long
run which is going to be
uh you know something i've done six to
eight times at least going into this
race and that just becomes something i
can easily wrap my head around
comparatively
and uh you know you're gonna still
probably hit some rough spots in there
but
kind of keeping that in the back your
mind as well as any like mini benchmarks
i like to be a little more like
present with my goals at that point
because you do are gonna you are gonna
get a variety of experiences from that
last part so like determining like am i
gonna focus on just getting the next two
miles done or am i gonna focus on a
bigger chunk is something i'll usually
leave to race day in that part but i'll
definitely be leaning on kind of that
mindset stuff i talked about before with
the long run development where i'm
thinking about like the various stages
in there
uh and like what i need to do when i
have a have a negative self self uh self
thought kind of come in
and the
the part that makes it really
interesting is
there's always a race
that you do
where you kind of push past some
discomfort or a mental block that you
hadn't done before
and you have this realization of like
you start second guessing your your your
mental strength or your willpower in
previous ones because you now you kind
of redefined what you're capable of and
you start wondering was it my mind that
limited me before that didn't get me
there or was i actually just not
physically able to do this yet at that
point and i think in most cases it's the
mental side of things
and
that can be both fulfilling and a little
uh
depressing depending on how you process
it so yeah i think you have to be kind
of careful especially post race then too
is going through the mindset of like you
know if you achieve something you never
have before
not to kind of be
hard on yourself for prior attempts yeah
for having never done it before dude
that's such an interesting thought
pattern i'm really glad you brought it
up the fact that a success in one moment
can highlight your failures previously
and you can almost tarnish the thing
that you're really proud of in the
moment by using that as a retrospective
benchmark to gauge all of the things
when you all the times when you didn't
do that previously it's so interesting
and i think it's there's also like uh
something i've thought about before and
said is just like there's really no such
thing as a perfect hundred miler because
it's just too long there's gonna be a
mistake or something happens that you
didn't anticipate or if you did
anticipate it you were hoping it for not
to happen and then it does and
it's a little like nebulous as to how
that impacts your final time but you
when you walk away from the event itself
you if you if you really review
everything you can find a few places
where it's like well if i had done that
a little differently i maybe saved
myself a minute or two so there's almost
this like this endless target of like
what you're capable of so i think there
is
and perhaps this is me coping but like
perhaps there is like some some value in
just acknowledging that when you're
doing something as long as 100 miles
there's really no way that every piece
to that puzzle fits absolutely perfectly
and there is no uncertainty throughout
it
uh so you at a certain point you have to
say hey i minimized the number of
mistakes and i responded to the
uncertainty as best i could and that's
what produced perfection for what i can
can expect out of this type of a project
how much discomfort do you go through
because you know for me somebody who if
i had to run five miles that would be
pretty ugly to me um
even with all of the training and even
with all of the preparation
pain and discomfort how much does that
play into
100 miles as a limiting factor
yeah i think the interesting thing
because i always try to compare this to
like earlier in my life because when i
got into running i was doing more
standard distance stuff like 5ks 10ks
and
it's really interesting to me because
with those type of endurance events
there's like a sharper pain that you
have to kind of white knuckle through
for however long it takes you 15 minutes
30 minutes whatever it happens to be
and that's just like a different type of
discomfort it's like a really sharp
acute discomfort
versus in ultra running it's like
nothing really
unless you really get hurt by like
falling or something like that i guess
like
nothing really hurts like super sharp
where you feel like it's like a stabbing
pain but there's like this low level of
discomfort that kind of arrives
somewhere around like the point where
you get to your longest long run
and it kind of just like stays there and
it doesn't go away so you have this like
low level discomfort
that just eats away of you and like
every hour every minute that goes by
it's like just one more hour one more
minute that you had to tolerate that low
level of discomfort
and i think that's really the big thing
you have to get over is physically you
could often push through a lot of that
but do you have the mental currency to
be able to actually kind of consciously
say this is uncomfortable i've been
managing this discomfort for x number of
hours already
i can do it for x a number more in order
to get to that finish line
and and this maybe goes into like what i
was just talking about where inevitably
during that time frame there's going to
be some moments where you're like i
don't know if i can do this and perhaps
that slows you down for a little bit or
causes you to take a break that you
maybe didn't necessarily actually need
to take that kind of adds up to the the
totality of the experience
um but yeah that's kind of a it's an
interesting question because it's like
the day after walking down the stairs
there's some sharp pain for sure
in the moment it's like it's it really
is i think just like you know this big
like like this long like
like subtle discomfort that you just
have to be able to you know in your mind
you feel like it's never going to turn
off and just like the prospect of living
through that
for however long it happens to be is can
get very overwhelming and that's where i
think people usually hit a hit a
roadblock and and sometimes drop out i
think you're right by making the
comparison between shorter runs that do
have a more
acute
sharp pain to them because that's what
most people have done most people don't
have a 12-hour or 24-hour event of
consistent but prepared low-level
discomfort that slowly gets worse over
time
so what i'm doing is i'm
extrapolating out like running
cross-country when i was in school or
something i'm thinking how hard was that
oh god imagine if that was what it was
like or you're doing a fran in crossfit
you know it's a seven minute workout
yeah
did you see that the
uh
rowing erg the c2 rowing erg 5k record
just got broken this week no homeboy
held a 153
for five kilometers
a 153
uh 1k split that's just
straight up disgusting yeah
he he was probably a puddle on the floor
after that he looked he looked pretty
happy in the photo but uh yeah just wild
and that's this sort of thing especially
if you've ever seen the the 2k record
which i think is kind of like the gold
standard for for the erg um you look at
those guys and that is
you know that's that's all out
effort there is there is a
tiny little bit of pacing i suppose
within the first half and then after
that they're just stamping on the face
of whoever it is that they hate the most
in the world you know for three minutes
straight and um
yeah i i understand what you mean i i
understand the distinction between that
real sharp in the moment vision has
condensed in and all the rest of it um
i'm going to guess as well that
there's not so much left in the tank
that even if you decided to put the
hammer down as hard as you could mile 97
to 100
how much of a difference can you even
make to your pace when you like if you
decide to completely empty it
is there some limitations in there with
regards to fatigue and nutrition and and
hydration and stuff like that
yeah i actually think hydration and
nutrition is probably the bigger
piece to that puzzle because you know as
you get as you start depleting your
muscle glycogen i think once you get
around about 40 of the capacities when
your body starts kind of increasing the
perceived effort at a given intensity so
you have this situation where like if
you find yourself at mile 97 and you're
like flirting with that number
you just might not have like
the
like to push as hard
if you push as hard as you would to
produce whatever fastest time you could
run in that distance
that level of discomfort is just going
to produce a much
slower time
so if you can stay like
as hydrated and fueled as possible which
is impossible actually like that you
can't actually consume
enough fuel or stay hydrated enough
you're going to have at least some
depreciation there that takes a certain
amount of intensity off the table at the
end there
uh so then it becomes like a best of the
worst type of a scenario where you want
to do as good a job as staying as
hydrated and as well fueled as you can
but know that you're probably not going
to be able to do
do it as perfectly as you would as like
when you start a 5k and you're have full
muscle glycogen and completely hydrated
so i think that's a big limiter there um
i also think it's just like mental
fatigue too because you get to these
like you described it perfectly you said
like when you're doing like this fast
like uh like rowing erg or like
like 3k or 5k race
you are at a point where like the
intensity picks up where you you tunnel
vision in
and you really can't even process any
other information other than like push
push push that's like all you can really
think about
whereas when you're at the in a hundred
mile race it's slow enough and that pain
is dull enough that you can think of a
variety of different things and that can
either work for you or against you so
like if you allow the thoughts to be
like i can't do this there's no way i
can go any faster
i'm at my limit then you just defined
your limit if you say that if you go
into that and you're thinking
i can go 10 seconds per mile faster
let's try it and then you temp that and
then you try a little more a little more
you you you can think about these things
you have the opportunity to actually
have a conversation in your head where i
just don't think you can do that with
the shorter endurance events like the
conversation is basically like
go or don't go and that's all the
further it can really get
this is why i think the tour de france
is so compelling because you get to see
the
discomfort and the struggle on the faces
of the riders right every single day or
every single stage and you get to watch
the
the battle
between them and themselves
them and their discomfort right
especially on the hill climbs and that's
why it's so compelling that's why i love
watching it so i also love watching the
longer crossfit events the short ones
are fun or whatever but i much prefer
watching the longer ones because you get
to see
outwardly what's happening a
representation of what's happening
inwardly right and the self-talk the
icon or can't do this oh he's put the
bar down what does him putting the power
down mean has he wanted to or is he
getting angry or is he doing whatever i
had um eddie jones who's the england
head rugby coach right so we've got the
world cup 2023 coming up next year he'll
be the guy that leads england's
world cup hopes hopefully for that and
uh
he was telling me this story about when
he goes to go and see players
um he's scouting players in the england
club the premier league
for rugby and he'll go and watch from
before the game begins from way before
the game begins
and i asked him what he looks for in the
players that are the absolute best that
he's considering bringing into the squad
and he said well obviously they need to
perform well right they need to be able
to play the game of rugby but that's
kind of par for the course i already
know that that's something they're going
to do so that's a bit of the focus but
most of the focus is actually on the way
that they interact with the training
staff before and after the game the way
that they help or don't help the other
players during that what are they like
as a teammate if the game's going well
what's their body language like if the
game's going badly what's their body
language like if they make a mistake
what's their self-talk like what's their
posture like how are they dealing with
the discomfort of something being on
their side or not being on their side
how much are they looking to the coaches
for advice and how much are they
continuing to just stick to their own
game plan he really wants people to be
um
like solitary uh lone rangers
and a self-contained unit within the
team he doesn't want them to be relying
on the coaching staff he wants them to
be very much sort of like sovereign
individuals when it comes to that i i
just thought that was a really
interesting way to look at things where
you think well
huh that's
that's kind of interesting that it's
less about the performance and more
about the stuff that isn't the
performance because that tells you what
is impacting the performance right where
is that coming from how is this person
performing or not oh well a lot of that
might be due to their self-talk and i
can see that easily when the other team
scores a try or when they just miss
their most recent kick of their penalty
or whatever it's pretty interesting
yeah yeah it seems like any of these
sports
you get into like i find that
fascinating because it's like
i think it's valuable for
anybody to have like a deep dive into
something physical like that so you
understand like all those details
because they're they're kind of
universal for all of them at the end of
the day but if you you don't know what
you don't know so like if i'm a casual
observer just watching the rugby game i
don't know anything other than maybe a
layer deep uh but if i've done another
sport where i've gone multiple layers
deep i can assume there's got to be some
really cool things going on back here
and that kind of i think just spurs the
curiosity of learning more about like
why they're doing what they're doing and
it adds a little more excitement to like
the viewing side of things
zach better ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with what
you're doing where should they go
so the easiest spot is my website at
zachbetter.com just
z-a-c-h-b-i-t-t-e-r.com and that's got
links to everything from my podcast
social media channels and things like
that is there anywhere that people can
watch the race that you're doing is that
going to be broadcast or no
yeah it's usually live stream i don't
think they've announced where it is yet
but uh if if folks check out my
instagram page i'll be putting updates
on there with live tracking and things
like that as well so good luck man i'm
rooting for you thanks a bunch it was a
blast coming on the show what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace